you know why Comedy Store comics are the
best because there's no host you at that
dude if you join ts just flame
throughout the room
there's nobody can go go eat a little
time you got the write-up yeah yeah just
go up there and you know dog stick like
a grown-ass man now the beauty is in my
opinion when they're killing when
they're killing like that like someone
like des and because there's no host I
like it more because then then not only
is the pressure but also the praise is
on you because it's like Joey gives you
a dope intro there already on fire right
you know how to ride the wave your
[ __ ] money versus someone kills and
like I just did a show someone kills and
a host goes up and it's just eating [ __ ]
for no [ __ ] reason you're like what
the [ __ ] are you doing also sometimes
when you're when they're introducing you
I've always had great intros I think
Dane Cook gave me the best intro ever
and I don't know him at all yet he did
what did he say just some really nice
stuff you got hot damn dude that's calm
you know give me the worst ever I think
and I love Nick Kroll but Nick Kroll why
would he say he was uh who's next Leo
shabbos this uh this is like a month ago
he is this guy he's fight in UFC so give
it up for Brendan Shaw oh that's nice
yeah that's really nice well thank
goodness thank you thanks for telling my
past and thanks for giving me any
credibility right now that I'm here I
come out P really this yeah at the main
room this guy went to Community College
20 years ago give it up for this is if I
can give you a C in biology abortions
just fake it just fake it that's how I
always just three baby daddies [ __ ]
fake it be fun fake it this guy's
awesome you've seen this guy he's great
blah blah blah blah blah that's what
every every pro fakes it you know I mean
or you just do a run why to us who Ron
White remembers everybody and nobody at
the exact same time everyone's in droves
I love this [ __ ] dude or you know SARS
first of all store or you know hold on
you know you know probably des Diaz ROM
white to me when they hit I think Diaz
is way harder to follow it when he's on
fire he is no Punk yeah but if I follow
him okay I always expect to eat a dogs
I'm like okay well blood see and it just
goes but the vibe is different because
it
cuz Thalia does the LEAs comedy can be
followed by your comedy pretty easily
just completely different yeah but but
Joey is in like I'll let his own lane of
storytelling I feel energy it's just so
different it's like it's like nothing
you've yeah but it's also top-shelf edgy
[ __ ] to talk about like yeah he's
talking about it yeah you I go like hey
I had a weird day driving but like you
know we just heard about eating ass for
15 minutes dude I one time had the
followed Joey Diaz at a Joe Rogan show
in San Jose which is the equivalent of
middling for Van Halen when the opening
act is David Lee Roth okay so Joey goes
up to us 15 minutes of eating ass and
I'm like what do I got to follow this I
go up there flatline for about 10
minutes how long how long ago is this
this was many moons gel now it's like
dude now it's like I could follow
anybody I don't really care about it
like recently like atoms would make me
file Brian Holtzman and back in the day
that was a [ __ ] that was work
that was work because he would either
destroy the room and everyone's like
that's great thing I've ever seen
or he would just piss everyone destroy
the room and everyone get mad yeah dude
I've seen him do that yell at a guy
until he walked out I didn't yell at him
as he walked him out she's but it's so
funny dude it's so funny to watch he
plays these mind games with people so
much that it's as a comic it's brilliant
how about as a fan it's probably hard
cuz you're like some nights are [ __ ]
brilliant and awesome and some nights
he's angry and off and weird and but
what's the story that's why it's so good
but else is doing that anywhere anywhere
ya know why is the store jumping when no
one else's well we got podcasts are
constantly talking about it and to look
who came up there and who is gigging
there right now everywhere else is like
political correctness gotta have
diversity also on these soars like
flames of the room or get the [ __ ] out
of here
crap crap but but also it comes through
from the door guys to anybody or guys
are all murder
right now monsters it is kind of creepy
honey you do some of the others see I
mean I you do some of the other rooms
too you go there how about trying to do
other people's rooms that they asked me
to come do them like I'd like mellow
does a bunch of different rooms there
okay anybody that has a different show
up buffs like that we feel the improv at
oh you mean outside of the guy yeah vibe
yeah no they're totally different vibe
[ __ ] well here's it's funny like I
wonder got the door guys sometimes to
come there just light that please like
in Montreal it's so funny every time
when I go there it's becoming more and
more like what I think it should be
where the crowds are like I did a
catalan Jeff oh yeah Kalyan said you
open for talents and how much like come
across the street what'd he say said you
bumped no is that what he [ __ ] said
and wait to see his old ass later today
[ __ ] I didn't phenomenal sorry I didn't
do leg kicks [ __ ] loser I wrote jokes
[ __ ]
no I did great actually it was really
[ __ ] good crowd no but the crowd it's
um but the crowd was so but what I'm
saying the truth is like I think
sometimes you go to those places in your
like I don't know if I can tell this
kind of joke here dude
not anymore a Jeff okay they love local
doing this is the emperor's new clothes
it only exists if you believe in it
that's exactly right dude it's a do to
john the road so you you know like
what's real
yeah but by the talk on instagram and
and twitter what's here and here it's
not real no see people real people day
in day out and you're on tour
yeah I can go [ __ ] straight dude I
think it's lemon Sacramento this Friday
Marlo's come see me this doesn't come
out for a month and a half
no but I'm thinking it's French Canada
so I'm like oh man maybe their attitudes
are different about certain things you
know I mean because they're in their own
little world and though they love the
food they love the baby feel from this
raw [ __ ] they like the raw [ __ ] they
love that yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]